police in huntington beach california
are mourning the death of an officer who
was killed saturday evening in a crash
near newport beach it happened hours
after another helicopter plummeted into
the water dangerously close to swimmers
in miami beach there you see the video
lily luciano reports you said helicopter
in the water the calls came in around 1
30 in the afternoon
a helicopter just went down to miami
surveillance video shows a helicopter
crashing into miami beach waters several
feet away from swimmers it sounded like
it was losing power and then hit the
water police say three people were on
board the privately owned chopper two of
the occupants were transported to
jackson memorial hospital a third
passenger was not injured
just hours later in california
a newport beach family's home security
camera captured a police helicopter with
what sounded like mechanical trouble
plunging into the water i just see it
come down you know immediately and i
just i heard a big bang first responders
tried to save the two huntington beach
police officers trapped underwater
the pilot initially hospitalized has
since been released a second officer
nicholas vela a 14-year department
veteran was killed
aviation is generally very safe but
accidents do happen aviation attorney
john gagliano says it's unlikely these
accidents were pilot errors the pilots
and all the police departments that i
know of are very highly trained with the
florida crash from the video it looked
like there was a loss of engine power so
it seems to me that mechanical problems
are implicated in both of these crashes
for cbs mornings i'm lilia luciano in
newport beach